This is more perfect. I'm Jad Abumrad.
So last season we profiled a guy named Edward Bloom.
This is a guy who, according to his critics,
had almost single handedly rolled back decades of civil rights law basically by
himself. Wasn't a lawyer, wasn't a politician,
but somehow he sort of found this way to play the courts to cook up just the
right case, find just the right plaintiff to target voting rights,
affirmative action,
all kinds of different laws that take race into account seem to us at the time
that he was sort of this hidden architect, not too much was known about him.
In fact, at the time that we did the story,
there was a big case of his targeting informative action that was coming before
the Supreme Court. And there were these moments where his plaintiff, plaintiff,
he had found this young white woman, Abby Fisher,
was on the steps of the Supreme Court giving an interview and he would literally
be,
be behind her in the shadows, like almost at the edge of the frame.
Which one's a no, like who is this guy? What's his story?
So A, we produce a profile and a,
what I'd like to do in this podcast is update that profile because recently I
talked to Ed Blum again about what he's up to now and it's really interesting,
maybe troubling depending on where you stand. So gonna play, uh,
a chunk of the original just to sort of set the context and then follow it with
the new interview.
And if you'd rather not hear the original skip to about minute 17,
otherwise, producer Catherine Wells starts us off again. We wanted to know like,
who is this guy? So she paid him a visit.
Yeah. So I went to Tallahassee. That's where he lives,
or he winters in Tallahassee. Oh Man. Golden retriever.
You walk in. What initially struck you?
His golden retriever is what initially struck me.
Literally physically nice meeting you. Of course.
And I don't know what I was expecting, but when you hear about these cases,
you know, there, I mean, critics are really, people are mad about these cases.
It is deeply disturbing, truly outrageous.
So betrayal of the American people.
So I go to meet him and your flight from Austin to Dallas to Tallahassee.
Uneventful and on time and good. Yep. Good.
He's like a totally nice guy. A regular guy was,
he looked like like a dad.
There is something in me that just loves tradition and custom.
He loves listening to the great American songbook. Life is a beautiful thing.
A Frank Sinatra. As long as I hold this string and
Ella Fitzgerald in heaven. I love art and museums. Uh,
independent films. Golf. What's this guy's backstory? Well,
he's 64 I born in a small town in Michigan.
My Dad owned a shoe store there. My mom worked with him in the shoe store.
What had been your kind of political leanings up to this point or, well,
I'm the first republican my mother ever met,
hate to use the word typical,
but it really was a typical liberal Jewish household.
My mother and father were Franklin Roosevelt. Harry Truman,
Democrats always voted Democrat, Minnesota.
He was that way too. All the way through college.
The University of Texas Grad School, State University of New York,
where I spent a year studying of all things
African literature,
but he says somewhere along the way his political leanings and sort of started
to shift. I spent a summer in Israel
living on a kibbutz and he says he came out of that experience a little less
liberal than he was before
and you got married and then in the early eighties he's living in Houston
working as a stock broker
and we met aren't our neighbors,
this particular couple, they were New Yorkers who had moved to Houston,
both grew up as liberals and the guy,
he sort of opened my eyes to the world of the neo-cons.
The guy introduced him to these magazines,
weekly Standard National Review Commentary magazine,
like conservative magazines,
and this was around the time that the neo-con movement was really hitting its
stride. You had all these New York liberals defecting is what he says.
Thousands of individuals who grew up in the 1960s that started to question the
wisdom of these liberal policies. And he says slowly,
slowly over time, very gradually he became one of those people.
And any case, fast forward a little bit, he's living in Houston,
kind of a garden variety existence and something happens that sends him on this
entirely new path. Basically, he and his wife moved to a new neighborhood.
They moved from the suburbs into the downtown area, more urban.
And in 1990 when we went to vote for the first time in our new neighborhood,
I realized that the Republican Party had not fielded a candidate to oppose the
Democrat incumbent running for Congress.
This is a district that has almost 600,000 people and you don't have a choice.
You've only got one person running. Blum decided to run himself.
I lost. I don't, that was no great surprise to anyone.
I actually lost by 32 points.
But along the way as something really happened, um,
during that campaign, he and his wife Lark, you know,
they decided they were going to go meet voters in their district.
They got a giant printouts of all of the addresses in the 18th congressional
district to what was then called a walking list.
And they just started going door to door meeting people,
handing out literature and they'd walk down say Oak Street.
I would take the even side of Oak Street and my wife would take the odd numbered
side of Oak Street and we would start to walk and,
and he says very quickly they realized that the districts shape was funny.
Some houses on one side of the street would be in the district and then houses
on the other side wouldn't.
And sometimes the district would sneak down a highway,
catch an apartment complex, come back. It just didn't make sense.
This is lark bloom wife of Edward Bloom.
It was peculiar because we had maps that we had to follow and it was very odd
the way some streets were in the districts and some weren't.
Took a while for it all to really sink in as to how this could happen. After,
I guess about a week of this,
we realized that neighbors had been separated almost house by house because of
their race.
He comes to believe that the reason this was done was for the explicit purpose
to create a majority African American district.
[inaudible]
this is an untrue, that's acne
flowed from a clear and simple wrong.
Part of the reason this was done was the voting rights act of 1960 5 million.
Oh,
the Americans are denied the right to vote because of their color.
This act was a giant step forward in civil rights.
You know,
one of the primary things that did is eliminate barriers to voting like poll
taxes and literacy tests. All these, you know,
strategies that had been used to keep minorities from voting.
And then this other thing it did sort of in a roundabout way through a series of
interpretations is it encouraged the creation of districts where the majority of
voters were minorities.
And that's because one of the strategies that had been used previously to,
um,
sort of dilute the minority vote was to take minority communities and they
called it cracking. They,
they sort of split them apart into many different districts so that they were
never in the majority enough to elect a representative. Right.
So the voting rights act tried to correct that.
The 18th congressional district was one of these majority minority districts
districts.
The district was drawn by the Texas legislature to have a slight African
American majority, I think about 51% African American.
But this was the problem according to bloom,
the way they got to that African American majority was by creating this district
that zigzagged all over the city and cut through neighborhoods.
I could not understand. People live close together.
They sent their kids to the neighborhood schools.
They shopped in the neighborhood shopping centers.
They were worried about neighborhood issues to break these neighborhoods apart
by race seemed so wrong to me.
In his mind,
this law was actually not limiting discrimination,
but actually perpetuating it. Well, yeah.
And I don't know what the average person upon realizing this would have done,
but I decided to file a lawsuit.
GE decided to sue the state of Texas,
called a few friends who lived in the 18th district,
a racially diverse group of people and African American, Hispanic, and an Asian.
Kept looking and looking and looking until I found a lawyer that I could afford
$7,000 a month.
We filed a lawsuit challenging the constitutionality of Texas's redistricting
plan. The basic charge was yes, the voting rights act was good in its day,
but now it was being used as this excuse to segregate people into racially
polarized districts. Kid worked its way through the lower courts.
And to my shock and surprise in 1995
well, your argument now, no number 94 eight oh five George W.
Bush versus Alvera,
the Supreme Court took it up and you went to oral arguments. Yeah, we all did.
Mr. Keith testified made please.
All right, so there we all are.
Our opponents stepped to the lectern and okay,
you can this direct appeal if the constitutionality of three congressional
districts,
they make their arguments.
Hello erroneous. We rule where racially Gerrymander,
Texas basically said, y'all, we have to put people together by race.
The Texas legislature has the obligation to satisfied federal requirements in
the voting rights act is a federal requirement.
Like remember the voting rights act.
We're trying to make sure that there are enough minorities in this district so
that they have a chance to elect a representative than our advocate,
the chief justice and may it please the court.
His arguments.
It's strict scrutiny. [inaudible]
Bloom's lawyer basically said, but look at the map.
The map is bizarre and the only reason it could have gotten this way is because
you're only thinking about race only race. Right? Think about it.
That seems messed up. Isn't that messed up?
It doesn't matter what your ultimate goal is.
You cannot use certain forbidding tools.
Race is forbidden by the 14th amendment to be used as a tool in,
in handling all the people at St Mary's. Yes.
You know, it's a very tense situation. Okay.
I'm not asking you about your situation.
Do you know any other situation in the mall in which we allow race to be used
as, it's not like it's fine to be unconstitutional,
but to use it as a more cross domain. How was this done?
I thought that's how you said they kind of see that or he'd be like, Hey,
it would require [inaudible]. You did say that, didn't you? Let me explain.
Let me find that. Did you say that or no? We want to make me
so in the end,
the supreme court gives out this very
hairsplitting decision that I think gets at this deeper question that in our
society and in our discourse,
we just haven't figured out how to talk about it in a way.
And it basically said this, you know, look,
if you're defining race just as the color of someone's skin,
the government cannot use that in any way. That's against the constitution.
On the other hand,
if you take this wider view and you look at race in the context of history,
social context,
then how can the government address discrimination without taking race into
account? They have to. So it's this difficult balance.
You can't look at race,
but you have to look at race and the Supreme Court says to Texas,
look,
all you're doing in this case is sorting people based on how they're labeled on
a census. You're not looking at that wider context.
You're not looking at if these communities live next to each other,
if they share common interests,
you're just sorting them based on race alone and that's not good enough.
You can't do that. When the opinion came down,
the supreme court ruled in our favor, five to four.
That was quite a day.
The day that we won that lawsuit, I was,
ah, I've got the world on a string hooked forever.
After that, Edward Bloom decided that this would be his thing.
It became a passion.
You would use the courts to try to strike down every race based policy he could
have. The legal team was taken on the road.
I recruited plaintiffs in New York for Virginia,
South Carolina to challenge Congressional district plans and we won in each of
those states.
He helped sue school districts in Florida and Texas to end the use of racial
quotas in k through 12 magnet schools.
[inaudible] after affirmative action in Houston city contracting today,
Houston could become the first city to kill affirmative action.
That one was actually a valid initiative and it failed,
but I've been the architect of over two dozen lawsuits,
six of which six made it to the supreme court, including
in 2013 and a five to four vote five to four very divided court.
The Supreme Court today struck down a key part of the voting rights act of 1965
supreme court today struck down a very important part of the voting rights act.
He 1965 landmark law.
It's considered one of the most important pieces of civil rights legislation
ever passed. Shelby county versus holder.
This decision gutted the voting rights act. Specifically.
There was this part of it that said states and counties with a history of
discrimination have to check with the federal government first before they go
about changing their voting laws. Basically the federal was saying, look,
you've been up to all this stuff where now we're watching you.
The Supreme Court said, you know, times have changed.
That list was made a long time ago, and it's outdated.
This decision restores an important constitutional order to our system of
government. This was Bloom's biggest victory when Shelby county came down.
I burst into tears.
I think a lot of people burst into tears when that came down. You know, it it,
yeah, I understand it
deeply disturbing. I am deeply disappointed,
deeply disappointed with the courts decision in this matter. Yes.
Decision as a beat trail of the American peaky.
That was a game changer. During the civil rights movement,
people died for the precious right to vote.
Congresswoman Sheila Jackson Lee of Houston, Texas.
I would like to have the Supreme Court justice as go back in time.
[inaudible]
go back in time and March with those who marched
after bloody Sunday. I'm from Selma to Montgomery.
Ed Blum has a right to his opinion.
It doesn't mean that it has to be the opinion of the United States.
I understand that people were, you know,
gravely upset and also know that there were people who were greatly relieved and
gravely gratified. Yeah,
but I think what gets a lot of people is that you look at the civil rights
videos, you see tens of thousands,
40,000 people in the streets marching and you hold that and if you make a split
screen in your mind, you hold that thousands,
tens of thousands of people on one side, on the other side, you one guy,
it does make you ask basic questions about democracy. That's a false paradigm.
It's, that may be your split screen,
but that's really not the reality of all of this.
You look in 1964 1965, uh,
America was held hostage by the legacies of slavery and the chokehold of Jim
Crow.
Fast forward to 2006 the reauthorization of the voting rights act,
the chokehold had gone away.
African Americans in the deep south registered to vote in numbers that often
exceeded whites,
participated in elections and numbers that exceeded whites in terms of electoral
opportunities.
We have come on 180 degrees from 1960 before we turn those degrees because of
the law, which you've helped overturn and, and, and,
and we don't know to what degree that is the psychology of America changing or
the fact that we had a law that kept people in line and now that law is gone and
now we see voter ID laws coming back into play,
which I think any like sane person would admit is it is, it is,
it is an attempt, a blatant attempt to disenfranchise people.
So it feels a little bit strange to, I mean, I completely agree with you.
Things have gotten better at the same time. I think,
well that was because of the law that's now gone. Um, look,
laws change, laws evolve and,
and at some point they need to come to an end.
[inaudible]
so after winning the Shelby county case,
ed Blum turned his attention to affirmative action.
Should universities be able to use racial preferences in college admissions?
You found a young white woman named Abigail Fisher.
Abigail Fisher believed her race may have hurt her chances to attend the
University of Texas.
There were people in my class with lower grades who weren't in all the
activities I was in who were being accepted into ut.
And the only other difference between us was the color of our skin.
Case goes to the Supreme Court. And in that case,
the Supreme Court has upheld the affirmative action program at the University of
Texas. Affirmative action.
Jenna and higher education is constitutional at bloom lost.
But at the end of that original piece,
he made it clear to us he wasn't giving up. I'm a long distance runner. Uh,
if there's something just emblematic about my personality,
I run long distances.
And even as the court was coming down with this decision against him,
he was planning his next move that's coming up next after the break.
More perfect is supported by ZipRecruiter. 2018 has begun.
And if you're setting new goals for your business, you need the right talent.
That's where zip recruiter comes in with one click,
zip recruiter posts your job to over 100 job boards.
Then they find the most qualified candidates and invite them to apply.
No wonder 80% of employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day. Zip Recruiter.
The smartest way to hire to try ZipRecruiter for free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/more perfect.
That's ziprecruiter.com/more perfect.
I'm Preet Bharara every weekend. My podcast. Stay tuned.
I answer your questions about what's really happening in Washington.
I wonder if it is legal for president Trump to initiate military action against
North Korea.
What happens if Mueller turns on an indictment against the president?
I just want to know, are you a table genius?
Subscribe to stay tuned from cafe and W NYC studios.
This is more perfect. Damn Chad. Boom, rod. All right,
so now let's bring the action up to the present.
After Ed Blum lost that Supreme Court case against the University of Texas last
year,
he kept the case going on the state level and he took aim at two more schools.
I have retained counsel to litigate Harvard's admissions policies and
University of North Carolina's admissions policies.
He formed an organization called students for fair admissions.
And this time the target was perceived discrimination against Asian Americans.
Case against Harvard is in the early stages,
but I recently called them up to just kind of get an update on this crusade.
The ultimate goal is to have the supreme court revisit.
It's we think,
unfortunate opinion and Fisher and end the use of race and ethnicity once and
for all.
That's the goal of this organization and this organization will stay active
until that happens.
Is this a situation where like with a ut you, uh,
actively recruited plaintiffs? Yes, it is. It is.
So I did with students for fair admissions,
what I did with the University of Texas,
and that is I'm working with friends and allies,
uh, who yearn for the day that race and ethnicity is not a part of university
admissions set up three new websites, Harvard,
not fair.org,
u n c not fair. Dot.
O R G and u w not
fair.org w being Wisconsin.
So it was our hope to find students who had been rejected from those three
schools,
willing to join students for fair admissions and let us proceed into federal
court. And that's, that's what we did. Ed Tell me,
he got hundreds of responses to these websites from students who felt like
they'd been discriminated against.
He went out it down to just the students he felt had the most merit.
I talked to the kids, I talked to their parents,
each of those kids and their parents who agreed to join and participate as sort
of a participating member in a lawsuit.
I got on a plane and went to visit with them,
learned about their background, let them ask me questions. And who are they?
Well, can you tell me about them? Well, for the Harvard case,
they are all Asian. Um,
many of them are uh, children of immigrant,
uh,
Chinese children of first generation Korean and Vietnamese and they have
relative academic records.
I mean just startlingly so perfect GPA, A's,
perfect sats and HTTS active in sports,
lots of volunteer efforts. And how many, how many of them are, uh,
directly associated with the case.
That is something that the judge in the Harvard case has placed under seal,
uh, wisely. And why? And I think, ah,
well we remember what happened with the,
the harassment of Abigail Fisher.
If you don't take your last on somewhere,
maybe if her grades didn't suck your dumb ass,
maybe you would've gotten into a good college.
Becky, with the bad grades, really happy,
you and your racist lawyer got shot down.
Abby was hounded.
Abby was threatened. Um,
we learned an important lesson and that is,
although there may be students who are brave enough to put their name on a
lawsuit,
the consequences can be dangerous and frightening.
So all of the students involved in those three cases, Harvard,
UNC,
and the University of Texas have standing as members of the organization and
their names, their addresses,
their email will never be made to the public. It's a, I mean,
it's a funny thing though because I mean, the idea of a plaintiff,
even if it is often, uh,
in a way a theatrical construct, it,
it's strange to have plaintiffs that you can't examine and that you can't say,
okay, well who are these people? Exactly. What are their circumstances?
And you're right, Abigail Fisher,
I think was the subject of some very hurtful kind of harassment at the same
time, who she was,
was a helpful starting point for the conversation about whether this should
exist. I mean,
affirmative action or whatever you would call this doesn't happen in the court.
It happens in the world that happens in society.
And this is something that affects all of us. Well,
th th th this is very common in federal lawsuits in the ACL,
which is a membership organization often sues in the name of the organization
disclosing only to the courts.
There are members who have been directly harmed by this.
So what we're doing is not unusual. Gotcha. Okay.
So you've said in interviews on this lawsuit that Asian American students are
being penalized for being a high achieving minority. How do you argue that,
that they're being penalized? Well, in litigation like this,
we know that the court allows the use of race and ethnicity and admissions.
What we also know is that you cannot as a university have too heavy of a hand
using race and ethnicity. And furthermore,
numeric quotas are completely forbidden.
And how we show that Asians are being targeted in the Harvard case is to look at
the number of Asians that have applied to Harvard and what percentage year after
year after year has Harvard admitted.
And what we found is that from 1992 through two and 13,
um,
the percentage of Asians that Harvard admits has been remarkably flat.
In fact, in 1992,
19% of Harvard's freshman class was Asian.
Wow. In 2013,
18% were Asian.
Now that doesn't mean much until you realize that the number of Asians applying
to Harvard during this period of time better than doubled.
Just a quick note here, uh,
Harvard hasn't actually released data on ethnicity and admissions for the years
he was talking about. So we can't confirm the numbers he just use.
We know that Ed Blum was drawing in part from the National Center for Education
Statistics, which is a government organization. And by the way,
when he says 19% of the freshman class,
it turns out the number he was using refers to more than just freshmen.
If those kinds of data points were presented in court,
in an employment lawsuit against a major corporation like Walmart,
Walmart would lose. Any judge would look at that and say,
you've got a quota. Walmart,
your employment practices fall afoul of title seven. Well,
let me just push back against that for a second. Um, you know, the, the,
that idea that you're expressing and the, and the sort of the fight, uh,
the sort of,
the spirit of the lawsuit is premised on this idea that if you take away race
based filtering in admissions,
that w what we would have as a more meritocratic system that's based purely on
grades. But I mean, hasn't the meritocracy,
isn't that just a myth? I mean, especially at a place like Harvard. I mean,
if you look at the data at Harvard,
you see the people whose parents went to Harvard,
who have family members who went to Harvard,
they get preferential treatment in the admissions process.
And if you take that out just a few rungs, okay.
People who have families that can afford to send them to Kaplan prep courses for
the standardized tests, will they get a better leg up?
And isn't that just kind of affirmative action for white people?
So there's two ways I want to answer that question.
The first is that it is not up to me,
it is not up to this organization, uh,
to dictate how Harvard or Texas or the University of North Carolina fashion
their admissions policy.
The only thing legally that we are advocating for is the end of racial
distinctions in the admissions process. Number two,
I agree that colleges and universities cannot use just strictly grades and sat
scores as an admissions criteria.
I believe legacy preferences should have been ended at Harvard and throughout
the country decades ago.
I think people who write big checks to universities whose children then get a
leg up in the admissions process. I think that ought to end.
I think the colleges and universities have an obligation to reach out to kids
from disadvantaged backgrounds.
Kids whose family income is small and below average,
whose parents didn't go to college,
who maybe grew up in a tough neighborhood.
Colleges should use that and not race if they're going to give a leg up in
helping kids from these disadvantaged backgrounds,
and that means that there will be lots of African American kids,
lots of Hispanics,
but also lots of Asians and lots of white kids that get,
you know, a helping hand from Harvard and Princeton and Yale and Stanford.
There is no reason why an Asian applicant to Harvard,
whose parents are laborers.
Mom works as a maid at a hotel in New York and dad works as a kitchen worker at
a Chinese restaurant.
There is no reason why that kid should be penalized.
And White Kids,
African American kids and Hispanic kids who come from professional backgrounds
should be elevated ending racial classifications and preferences and instead
substituting socioeconomic preferences is something that both the left and the
right can agree on.
But it's interesting to think about what might happen in the transitional space
between say an ED balloon victory and that remedied admission system.
Cause I was just thinking I might.
Okay so take someone like Abigail Fisher and let's hold her in the right side of
our mind and the left side of our mind.
Let's say you get the Harvard case to Scotus and you win and the court agrees
that there is some kind of quota in place and they no longer support that there
should not be any kind of limit on high how many high achieving Asian American
students get into Harvard or any university.
It's interesting to think of the effect that might have on white applicants like
Abigail Fisher. Well we make this argument in our lawsuit.
The argument is that African Americans,
Hispanics and whites are getting a preference over better qualified Asian
applicants. So it is very likely.
And what interesting is Andy Whites, so you leave you.
We asserted that in our lawsuit,
so this is not an attempt to, I don't know,
reinvigorate,
protect white applicants at all of the Ivy League and schools like Duke and
Stanford outside of the Ivy League. Well,
the number of whites is likely to go down.
The number of Asians is likely to go up. That's,
that's why we don't have any whites as plaintiffs in our Harvard lawsuit.
That's why none of the kids that join students for fair admissions to challenge
Harvard we're white is because they're benefiting from the discrimination that
Asians are suffering there.
[inaudible]
that's Edward Bloom.
Harvard sent us a statement which didn't directly respond to Ed Blum specific
allegations,
but they did say that they do make an effort to create diversity in their
student body because when a student encounters diverse types of people with
diverse experiences,
that student grows and you can read their full statement on our website,
but we'll also have some additional information about the lawsuits we talked
about, which again are in the early stages. That's it.
radiolab.org/more perfect.
[inaudible]
more perfect is produced by me, Jenn Ivan, Rod, Susie Lichtenberg, Jenny Lawton,
Julia Longoria, Kelly Prime, Alex Overington,
Sar Cari with Ellie Ms Stall, Christian Pfarius, Linda Hirshman, David Gable,
and Michelle Harris.
[inaudible]
special thanks to Katherine Wells who produced our episode called the imperfect
plaintiffs. Go back and listen to the whole thing. If you haven't,
that's pretty good. Supreme Court audio is from OEA,
a free law project in collaboration with legal information institute at Cornell.
Leadership support for more perfect is provided by the Joyce Foundation.
Additional funding is provided by the Charles if it's Hughes Memorial
Foundation.